I just got back from the grocery store I
found this branch of brussel sprout and
never in my life did I think I'd get so
excited about a baseball bat of Brussels
sprout hi I'm Hannah and I'm the world's
okay it's mom and this is about the
amount of trash my family generates in
one week now I don't know what the norm
is but this seems like a lot so I want
to try something for one week our
family's gonna try to live zero waste
now I don't even know where to begin or
how this is gonna go but we're gonna
give it a try so wishes luck so what is
zero waste it is trying to generate as
little landfill waste as possible so
anything that would end up in a landfill
we don't want none of that in our house
we as a family are going to attempt to
generate zero waste and I'm talking food
waste I'm talking trash packaging you
know number one in two ways just fine
that doesn't count yes you can poop what
I want to do with this week is highlight
every single small doable easy way for
us as a family to reduce our waste and
use those going forward so we are doing
a little research we are going to read
some testimonials of people who have
gone zero waste to learning some tips
and tricks to make it a little bit
easier matt is on the case I'm on the
case okay I'm here at Whole Foods I'm
kind of intimidated so day one the
dreaded grocery shopping trip I usually
go grocery shopping in the pajamas I
wore the night before and I feel like
Whole Foods is a little more of a scene
my goal is I at least buy a third of
what I need so let's see if this works
whole dude did come through
with these reusable produce that so I
went and I got in there and then I just
used them and paid for them as I checked
out but they come with packaging so
first piece away
the irony of your reusable produce bags
coming in a crap ton of packaging it's
just it's priceless who do you think
you're making this product for people
who want to waste less so I lettuce to
make a salad these bell peppers because
they came in this tomatoes for my salad
after that shopping trip I didn't have
very much at all most notably I had no
bread every piece of bread at the
grocery store is heavily packaged so day
two I knew I had to do something
different so Jax and I are headed to the
farmers market
he was kind of in a mood I don't know if
you've noticed lately but as he's
getting a little older he's getting a
little more emo I let him simmer he just
wants to be left alone and left to his
thoughts and then he snaps out of it so
emo Jackson at the farmers market with
me you ready okay let's go so I figured
going to the farmers market would be the
best place to get bread package free
because it's the bakers themselves
bringing everything to the farmers
market so they probably don't have
everything completely packaged there we
got a lot of what we needed we got bread
we got some berries we got plums and we
got these cool purple and white beans we
got a couple eggs now I had heard that
at most farmers markets there will be
booths of bulk cleaning products and
bath and body products not this farmers
market I didn't find any so I ended up
resorting to making my own so for now
the only DIY household product that I
can really fathom making is an
all-purpose cleaner
it has vinegar lemon juice and a little
dish soap so I just ran out of honey
all-purpose cleaner so this is actually
perfect so I have an empty bottle that
I'm going to make this in and let's see
how it turns out I made a little sampler
I'm gonna test this out see how it works
we're used to the smell of cleaning
products being like floral fresh clean
linen and this vinegar smell oh boy Oh
pungent I mean probably better than
chemicals right so I woke up this
morning and why we're both pretty sick
but I'm still gonna do this I'm going to
attempt to make a zero-waste lunch I'm
used to putting everything in just
resealable plastic bags in the lunch
boxes so I pulled out a bunch of
Tupperware and then I found this other
really cool product it's a beeswax wrap
and it's reusable so I wrapped Jackson's
sandwich in that and then I was super
nervous sending it with him to school
because his instinct is to just throw
everything in the trash when he's
finished and if he threw away my $10
beeswax wrap there would have been some
problems this is very expensive so we
don't throw this in the trash okay
when you're when you unwrap your
sandwich just put it back in your
lunchbox okay Jackson promised and I
just crossed my fingers and hoped for
the best for breakfast today we're going
to try our duck eggs now duck eggs are
not anything that any of us have eaten
before so thank you farmers market for
introducing us to it and see what it
looks like the biggest difference that
we noticed that morning for breakfast
was that they're larger the yolks are
bigger and they're a little bit silkier
you excited it on it yeah taste it all
right what do you think
pretty good tastes exactly the same I
wasn't doing a difference today decades
who knew I'm gonna have a duck coop out
in the back of my house one of these
days maybe so Dave for was a load of
crap
literally Rosie oh my goodness
don't go hiding look what she did she
pooped on the floor I am using paper
towels for this and I'm not going to
save them in my waste bin all right
waste jar thought isn't so gross so
gross that was kind of a fail but I feel
like I get a free pass for that because
I'm not picking that up with my hands so
speaking of paper towels I wasn't using
any so very quickly my dish towel supply
dried up and my washing machine filled
up dirty every dish towel in my entire
house dish towels they kind of were the
hero product of the week I used dish
towels to save the day so we decided to
go out to eat I came fully prepared when
we went out to eat I am going to bring a
dish towel for all of us to share
instead of a napkin and I brought
silverware just in case and it was a
success we looked very ridiculous all
wiping our mouths on one large dish
towel but I don't even care at this
point I have no shame anymore you know
hey bye why are you upset do you want to
talk about it so day five was the
inevitable day of any week like this
this is the day it all fell apart okay
will you tell me when you want to talk
about it when you're ready
okay we were having trouble surviving
like this food-wise we couldn't live off
of fruit for much longer so I did
something I'm not proud of all right
we cave did we order takeout I know
that's a lot of plastic you know what
rome wasn't built in a day yeah yeah I
know we can't all be perfect okay some
of us need a cheat day or two so you're
going to take these egg shells and crack
them up and we're gonna put them on our
soil so I'm good I'm gonna make it eight
no it doesn't grow eggs so day six was
all about reduce reuse recycle and we
had lots of little projects to get done
that day we are cleaning up the boys
room and we found some Lego boxes I
think we can use these for something
else instead of just throwing them away
should we try an arts and crafts project
it is a special box it's all wrapped
when you guys get to color on this we
have colored pencils and markers and
let's decorate this okay Alexes and
there's the polar bears on the roof here
Steve and here's Alan white what are you
making what is this
okay so we are going to use these to
store mismatched socks excellent and at
the end of our big recycling day I had a
major mission to accomplish this is my
little compost bowl that I'm going to
keep in my freezer I'm gonna try to find
somebody who will take the compost so
what I ended up doing was joining a
Facebook group with like-minded people
and I found somebody who composts
themselves so I'm here I'm by myself I
wish I had brought somebody it feels
kind of like a Craigslist meetup or it
kind of feels like a drug deal I got
that do you need these it is done it is
done the deed is done we did it
I feel alive right now got rid of my
compost yeah oh my god I'm too pumped on
this alright I gotta go tonight we are
having my friends over for dinner we
have two friends that we haven't seen in
a very long time so about a month and a
half ago I invited some friends over to
a dinner party and we planned this way
in advance and of course in true Hanna
fashion I completely forgot about it so
I had to plan a zero-waste dinner party
I don't even know where to begin with
feeding people and one thing's for sure
I don't think we can serve any meat
because how are you gonna take me home
from the grocery store so I think meat
off the table I really hope that we can
make something filling instead
like some raw vegetables I don't even
know where I'm gonna start now I really
wanted to make a cheese board just cuz
I'm known for having really big
beautiful cheese boards when people come
over like I'll eat a cheese board for
dinner instead of food it's my favorite
thing in the world what ended up
happening with this cheese board is it
had a lot of very odd ingredients on it
that you wouldn't expect on a cheese
board mmm there was some dragon fruit
just a bunch of random like jarred stuff
like cocktail onions and olives and
bruschetta sauce and I don't know it was
a cluster but it looked good so how did
the dinner party go Wow how'd it go away
Oh so how did the dinner party go Wow
the food two three times as long as it
needed to do they ended up spending so
much time cooking and my friends who
came and then I'm helping Pete cook so
we're just kind of in the kitchen the
whole time but I made a mistake I just
out of habit I roasted my pumpkins on a
piece of foil and I didn't even notice I
was doing it I was patting myself on the
back or not generating any waste and
blah blah blah and then I went to clean
up and I realized I had this piece of
foil in my pants so into the waste jar
it goes and just like that seven days
came and went zero waste week was over
it was pretty easy for everybody except
me but that was to be expected and this
is what we have to show for it
I collected our waste in this jar it is
a little overflowing but I'm pretty
proud if this is the majority of our
waste compared to what we usually do
this is huge
so that's I got for today I'm Hannah and
if you have an idea for a future episode
leave it in the comments or you can
always text me this is a real number and
I don't always respond cuz I get a lot
but I do read every single one now if
you'll please excuse me I have a ton of
dish towels left wash till next time
[Music]
listen in these ingredients homemade
deodorant been a night clay arrowroot
powder sure this is so easy let me just
tap into my stash with bentonite clay
but I keep in my pantry like where what
[Music]